se non vi è bastata la puntata dove ho
mangiato skipe se non vi passeranno
anche questa perderti ragazzi venuti qui
sono video io sono la vj e oggi andiamo
ad e scatolare un palco speciale
ok allora dall'ultima volta ragazzi che
ho fatto
adottiamo quanto ragazzi che ho fatto
degli assaggi di cibi non ho digerito
per 2 3 giorni dalla regia mi dicono che
questa volta la il contenuto è un po più
slim è che possiamo degustare le nostre
prelibatezze ovviamente cucina
napoletana e volatile largo se siamo
così molto bello ma non è successo
[Musica]
come possiamo intravedere ci sono un
sacco di cose che stuzzicano il palato
ora vivo io sono stato nel miglior
ristorante americano e all'interno
trovato un sacco di cose che sto vedendo
in questo momento ma che non ho mai
avuto il coraggio di assaggiare dei
vicari grandi made with love la meglio
anche rashk in forza vj thank you so
much american crime scheme for mail this
box with love for quali j
no no no questa non la posso assaggiare
queste da soprammobile ragata crema di
funghi campbell
che trovi nei bunker dei film o no
questi sixty seconds era sotto di sì xvi
secolo
no ryan abate aprire questo ben di dio
noche l'altro per tutta la qualità e
regioni ingredienti scritti italiano
acqua funghi olio di colza siamo già un
nome maschile addensante prossimo non
allora partì scherzi perché mi farebbe
veramente vomitare ma non è per quello
che non la mangiano perché voglio
ottenerla integra bellissima come
soprammobile e poi ho tempo fino al
dicembre 2019 perché scade nel dicembre
2019 per mangiarla quindi se impazzisco
se donald trump fa più casino di quelli
che ha promesso arrivare potrebbe
tornarmi utile da tengo la parte come
promesso devo mangiare tutto quindi
siccome non mangio questo mangerò il
doppio di un'altra cosa
tipo la lega pro
non lo so se io me è molto più no mica
di tre loro baracca esatte
apriamo la questo punto non ho mai
assaggiato la chiama il formaggio quella
che si vede nei film come si fa a fare
questa cosa
[Applauso]
allora io sono a roma un po più easy
cioè senso da mangiare il resto queste
sono le ferite che sono le patatine più
più vendute in america e 3d sono può
essere qua vedevano san carlo qua in
america vedi sole doritos solo veste di
no non ho mai st orlando riso mais
quindi proviamo a vedere questa notte la
loro forma è veramente strana l'odore è
fortissimo noeckler non capito il
discorso va beh mi sembra che proviamo
sopra patatina americano cioè il gusto
le valli america e questo certamente
incredibile sembra sembra finto e data
elsa lane vero e te lo mangi con il filo
di formaggio siete veramente i numeri
america veramente non so come mai non mi
sono ancora trasferito lì non trova
ancora motivazioni del rimanere in
italia
dunque apriamo le testate sembra
veramente cibo per cani
se esiste un dio ma la savana gente dal
buonissimo ci sono due uguali
scherzavo governiamo insieme abbiamo le
cheetos gronchi è lecito slam in bot
quindi quelle normali quelle di canti
khoomii fonzie
vogliamo prima quelle normali allora io
come sapete ciò dei problemi col
piccante però le normali normali
sembrano già piccanti c'è vedere stava
da milanista di piccantissima e non è
ficcante non sa di niente
fake possono cronici vogliamo quelle i
campi praticante lo detesto solo odio
non esiste hanno il colore della morte è
la calabria può dentro intera vado il
cantè 104 volte poi tantissimo
l'odio il piccante io lo sento
tantissimo è un po strano sulla cosa che
mi sembra meno strana di tutti abbiamo
diana jerky e carne essiccata e carne
essiccata di nativi avrei capito che gli
italiani mangiano questo quando vanno
mamma mia come mi sento indiano o mi ha
distrutto la bocca o le cose di prima
non sa veramente di niente e al bite of
energy il vero morse dell'energia cioè
dovrei sentirmi tipo un braccio di ferro
non lo definisce vabbè next non so
niente
purtroppo però è bello la toscana di
spam che non è quello delle vostre mail
quello è nato questo è meglio questo lo
spam e proprio bunker come la roba di
prima a tono semplicemente non sa quelli
sono pezzetti di carne di maiale questa
la posizione di chi fuori sconsolata
carne vero negli spazi carne cento per
cento americana però che vengono un po
più su carne cento per cento americana
per il vostro palato
mi spiace non volevo farlo conservarmi
queste cose invece non so da mangiare ma
sono come condimento sono le salse
americane quindi abbiamo la mostarda non
sta bene e le scemi l'originale salsa
red orange cioè patatine si fa vomitare
questo invece per la mostarda col miele
ma scusami madonna l'olio del motore che
lo voglio con questa valducci da 500
vari un piacere
mammamia orribile non so di massa tante
cose grazie a dio
però abbiamo pringles alla pizza dove
l'americano incontra l'italiano a napoli
vorremmo la pizza le pringles poi gli
americani sono tutto il loro senso di
pizza quindi la pizza no non sapranno di
pizarro però vabbè il colore per quello
della pizza noi incredibile no a 6
assurdo sono veramente di pizza sanno
veramente di pizza quella lercio e
comunque vita quella americana
che trovi con lo smog one questo vengo
normale rimangono poche cose e mi piange
il cuore però tra queste poche cose che
rimangono direi di tirare fuori queste
due sono sempre della doritos però non
solo patatine e la cosa mi sconvolge
troviamo la mattina ma non abbiamo né
doritos siamo la salsa di solito suprema
un insieme alla ragazza
l'importante è avere un fisico perso
allevatore di uplay morgan mi sei
piaciuta
diamo una mente a questa ragazza nella
troupe è molto buona soprattutto sono
più curioso dell'altro perché la 3 molto
che c'ha posa 9 beh veramente si
mangiano questo sito
non male non male penso molto bello sul
mio letto mi piace il corso in tutta
roma quasi tutta l'ultima prelibatezza
di oggi ragazzi e in coppia anche questa
e se parlando del con box perché sono in
due quindi un confort
[Musica]
avete capito bene allora direi di
provare prima e con boss peperoni e
pizza né speroni in questo caso si
dovranno sentire che non si sente nei
peperoni male non vada questo quindi il
peperone si sente sono fra i carri pieni
di un bel peroni prisco pizza gli
americani non sanno manco loro cosa
fanno mettono insieme cose avrà buono
comitiva bene andiamo sul combos c'è di
darcis eccetera non è già un formaggio
di solo 15 eder più cise bot
andiamo a provarli e non erano meglio
quelli di prima però ormai c'era un 4
quindi ragazzi spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto ho fatto un sacco di assaggi e
il router o fino a dopo normali però da
allora tutto sommato nelle schifezze ci
sanno fare le c'è nel senso alle feste
ti diverti sicuro di più forse lei che
qua perché qua sono trova in molto
raffinati per il lanciano tutte ste
cagate quindi ragazzi spero che viene vi
sia piaciuto ringrazia make a cannes e
ringraziamenti cancan cioè hanno inviato
con amore tutte queste prelibatezze cosa
non mi piace anche perché l'economia
domestica rischiate non ci vediamo
allora possiamo ragazzi
[Musica]